that last challenge review and it's
83-67
you think about it's probably about a
five-minute rest
these guys can play huge minutes
whistling we got a little uh altercation
between jokic
and beverly beverly
seemingly in the middle of a lot of
stuff but he walked away from whatever
was happening
well good no call there
[Applause]
and that's okay that's a foul yeah yeah
on your kids
and he did it meets the criteria
fountain
i certainly wouldn't think that's a
flagrant foul though
that beverly just walked away said i'm a
peaceful man
boy this is a game devoid of any kind of
flow or rhythm
with these uh fouls like that and
stoppages
for challenges
it was beverly that said in the
post-game news conference after
the game three win that it's jokic who
forces the officials to make tough calls
because of his
flailing
to which michael malone said i don't
really listen a whole lot to what
pat beverly says about jokic or the
calls
that was his frustration with shooting
16 less free throws
yeah than the clippers yeah they only
shot 10 in the whole game last game
common foul meanwhile on jokic just his
fourth personal foul
7 29 to go the clippers will inbound in
the backcourt
it's leonard beverly mantras harrell